we both like to travel the world as we
can and see things I love it and and
you've been doing a lot of that and
you've been you're a pretty adventurous
with food yeah when you travel you like
to really dive in there and try the
different foods try you know I feel like
it's a responsibility if you're visiting
and some of the food is like I was in
Asia some of the food you know it's
different you know I mean like I had you
know I was with a friend who she was
from Taiwan and and I tried a tea egg
which is essentially an egg boiled in
tea mm-hmm which sounds gross and it is
but what's really what specifically is
gross about it
well you bite in and the yolk is green
and you're like I don't know it's like
this isn't st. Patrick's Day but it's it
also has a strange odor but like that
was the alternative to this
thousand-year egg which you're like I
don't even wanna there's a thousand
reasons not to have that but you know
just how as a westerner we view it I
mean that's like we're with someone and
they're like we they think blue cheese
is gross but like there's just weird
things like in Seoul they had a pastry
shape like the poop emoji what you know
already appetizing right so but here's
the thing here's what you have to
understand in Asia which you've been
there you know this in Asia beans are
for dessert you're like I don't know why
beans are for dessert yeah I try and
keep an open mind like did they run out
of chocolate
so we we give them beans but like
there's this poop emoji that was on sale
that was either filled with chocolate or
beans if you get a OOP emoji
filled with beans so many levels of no
but it was amazing yeah I think we have
a picture of the the pastry
there's the poop emoji I love that that
I don't know what it's saying but it's
clearly apologizing they're all there
and they are all in on that delectable
poop theme I don't know if you have the
hello x1 which this is a napkin
dispensers that you came across why it's
like the Koreans are known for such
technology